melrose place i can hear the theme song
in my head right now the show turns
30 next year y'all but we are going to
pre-party tonight
our iconic leading men of the 90s tv is
feeling
all kinds of love for mr grant show
we are here in atlanta because we have
this series our iconic leading
men of the 90s and so you who's news to
me
okay i wish you didn't have to sleep on
it to come to that decision
you're waiting for someone to tap you on
the shoulder and say we made a mistake
here pal
it's not you
[Music]
let me just say this when we first saw
you on that motorcycle that was iconic
see now that wasn't me that was that was
jake i wasn't like that
i was like kind of a dorky guy well at
59 years old grant is just as hot
and humble as ever audiences were first
introduced to melrose place's resident
womanizer jake hansen in 1992
when he showed up in aaron spelling's
other show beverly hills 90210
looking good yeah it's almost finished i
was talking about you
what do you remember most about your
time on the set of beverly hills 90210
you know i remember
like building a gazebo in the back of
jenny garth's character's house and i
was so young
i don't really remember much about it
well that's when e.t first met a then
30 year old grant during his first e.t
interview i
actually just wanted to play you just a
clip from an early
interview that we oh my god i'm see
you're going to see what a nerd i was
still am i was kind of
about walking on that set with all those
kids who are sitting on top of the world
right now
and i was just wonderfully surprised
at how down to earth and how well they
treated me
what do you think of that young man he's
faking it real well
you picked a good clip thank you
on july 8th 1992 melrose place made its
much
hype premiere on fox and for five
seasons grant's character pretty much
hooked up with every lady in the complex
whatever happened to love thy neighbor
that's cute jack
come here but here's a behind-the-scenes
secret i did not see coming about his
on-screen romance with joe
played by daphne zuniga
and you know i asked them not to hire
her really
yeah that's terrible of me
[Music]
daphne and i both went to ucla at
different times
i was in new york at a restaurant and
she was at a table so i went over and i
introduced myself i said
you don't know me my name's grant we
both went to ucla we we have a lot of
mutual friends and she just looked up a
bit for me and she went like this
no the real jake
so i was like i do not want this person
working with me
no calm down no i'm not gonna calm down
thank god they didn't listen to me and
they hired her
and i love her and and we still talk i
gotta ask
if you ever think about a reboot or a
revisit and would you do it
some of the uh girls from the show have
been talking with fox about doing
something so yeah of course i would i'm
pretty busy doing dynasty and love
dynasty
you ready i'm having so much fun right
now i can't tell you well marriage isn't
always picture perfect
catch grant on may 7th when season four
of dynasty returns
on the cw can you tease something about
this new season
someone dies oh come on that's someone
you care about
ah no are y'all ready for that because
i'm not
now tomorrow from l.a law to nypd blue
our iconic leading men of 90s tv is
celebrating the fabulous mr jimmy smits
is he ready to return to his prime time
roots you'll find out